are you a fire emblem fan well now you
have a new option for picking up the
next 3ds title I'm Tony and this is your
special edition gamespot news update
fire emblem echoes shadows of Valencia
is a reimagining of Fire Emblem guide n
which featured a free-roaming world to
explore back on the NES and now the
limited edition of echoes has been
revealed for an extra 20 bucks you'll
get an art book CD and a set of
character pins in addition to the game
itself which includes reversible box art
inspired by the original NES game
that'll cost you 60 dollars altogether
when the game releases on May nineteen
and don't forget to subscribe to get our
future review sent right to you Fire
Emblem echoes launches alongside new
amoeba figures for protagonists Alleman
Celica which can be used to unlock extra
dungeons and some and temporary units
for battle echoes isn't the only Fire
Emblem game plan for this year either
check out our Nintendo switch exclusives
video for more on Fire Emblem warriors
[Music]